you know orwell analogies are terribly
overused these days but there's a
there's a reason for that well there's
two reasons one is that 1984 is one of
about three books that the average
american has actually read all the way
through the other two are harry potter
books but the second reason is that so
much of what we're experiencing today
really was prophesied by orwell in 1984
and even more so in my opinion in this
allegory animal farm things tend to
happen that even a more widely read
person cannot help but compare to one of
those two works and what else are we
supposed to do when the bite
administration as they did this week
literally creates a ministry of truth
sure i mean they aren't calling it that
of course instead they they've come up
with an even more orwellian name than
what orwell chose their name is the
disinformation governance board now this
new board will exist within
the department of homeland security a
department that shouldn't exist and
which has since its conception been
responsible for many of the federal
government's most insidious civil rights
abuses yet another reason to thank
george w bush for his contributions to
massively expanding the federal
government
the head of this new board is a leftist
ideologue an activist named nina
jankowitz who proudly announced her new
position in a tweet yesterday which you
can see here she posted
here's my official portrait to grab your
attention
now that i've got it a huge focus of our
work and indeed one of the key reasons
the board was established is to maintain
the department's commitment to
protecting free speech privacy civil
rights
and civil liberties and then for
whatever reason she includes a photo of
quentin tarantino
the interesting thing to note about this
nina character is that
she's not only a leftist but also and
these two things often come together as
a package deal
of course completely insane as evidenced
by this video which has been making the
rounds since tucker carlson played it on
a show last night but if you didn't see
it
i think it's worth watching because this
again this is a woman who's going to be
at the department homeland security in
charge of
disinformation
and here's what she's all about
information laundering is really quite
ferocious it's when a hawkster takes
some lies and makes them sound
precocious by saying them in congress or
a mainstream outlet so disinformation's
origins are slightly less atrocious
it's how you hide a delightful glide
it's how you hide a little light a
little lie it's how you hide little
idols alive when rudy giuliani shared
that intel from ukraine or when
tick-tock and flu and so say covet can
cause pain they're laundering december
when we really should take note and not
support their lives with our wallet
voiceovers
this is
perhaps not quite as embarrassing as the
bdsm dog fetishist that biden tapped for
a federal post a few months ago but it's
pretty close
not surprisingly nina is also a
proponent of the words our violence
school of thought she has a book coming
out apparently called how to be a woman
online
don't ask her to define what a woman is
though i mean she's just the
informations are she's not a biologist
and she tweeted this excerpt from the
book
um quote
men burst violently into your mentions
and your life like the kool-aid man
demanding your attention hawking
opinions that they believe are
unarguably manifestly correct and
indispensable
yes men are committing violence by
responding to your tweets
sounds a bit like taylor lorenz this is
a common theme
and this is men of course just men men
men only women never do this but men
also commit the sin of
thinking their opinions are correct now
never mind that literally every human on
earth thinks their opinions are correct
this is this is an accusation made
against me all the time oh matt you
always act like you think your opinions
are correct well of course if i didn't
think they were correct they wouldn't be
my opinion that by definition it's
something that i think is correct
perhaps most importantly of all though
nina who will be in charge of
identifying and censoring disinformation
has already made clear
what the term disinformation means to
her it means any information that is
politically inconvenient to democrats
which is why she labeled the hunter
laptop story disinformation back in
2020. she was one of like every other
democrat saying that that was
disinformation turns out it was 100
percent true
that point about the hunter biden laptop
story was made to jen pasake during the
white house press briefing yesterday and
here's how she responded to that listen
she had previously called the hunter
biden laptop a trump campaign product um
seeming to discredit its validity or
validity of reporting surrounding that
um
how can can you assuage concerns of
people who are looking at this person
who's been appointed to this position
and wondering if she's going to be able
to accurately judge misinformation now
that a lot of that reporting has been
proven to be
factual in some ways well i don't have
any comments on the laptop but what i
can tell you is that it sounds like the
objective of the board is to prevent
disinformation and misinformation from
traveling around the country in a range
of communities i'm not sure who opposes
that effort
she doesn't have any comments about the
laptop angle which is that's the
question right so i i love that from jen
pasake when someone asks a question and
her response is well i don't have any
comments about the question you just
asked so instead i'll make a point
that's irrelevant
she says the board will prevent
disinformation and misinformation from
traveling around the country in a range
of communities and she's not sure who
opposes that effort well many of us do
and um let me explain why first of all
note how they are calling i think this
is important okay they are calling it
the disinformation board and not the
misinformation board
now even that small nuance is
significant because it adds an extra
layer of editorializing
misinformation is simply information
that's wrong
disinformation is wrong is information
that's wrong intentionally
so all disinformation is misinformation
but not all misinformation is
disinformation
this information is when there's an
intentional there's a there's an intent
to deceive
the government now has claimed the
authority not only to be the arbiter of
which information is correct and
incorrect but also of the motivations
behind the people spreading the alleged
incorrect information
when you call something disinformation
you are claiming to know both that the
information is wrong and also why it's
wrong
this is the power the administration is
claiming for itself and it it can't end
well
i mean it's designed to not end well it
never does end well when a government
declares itself the final judge of truth
which is not the government's job
it's also not the government's job to
control the spread of information
it's supposed to control other things
and the spreads of spread of other
things like um immigration crime okay
those are these are two big ones that it
should be trying to control
but this regime has a little interest in
that
to this regime the greatest enemy is not
crime not anything like that it's
information
and because we live in the information
age
when the average person processes more
information in a day than previous
generations may have encountered in a
year or a decade
that means that the efforts to control
and stifle information will have have to
be far-reaching and severe and
oppressive
just think about what tyrannical regimes
in the past have done to control the
flow of information before the internet
before me uh modern media
now think about what this one will have
to do
given how ubiquitous information is
now the truth is that they will not be
able to staunch the flow completely or
monitor all of it though they will no
doubt try they're not going to be able
to do it ultimately
the most effective tactic they can take
and have taken have already taken
against inconvenient information which
again is what they mean by
disinformation
there's the actual definition of
disinformation which is incorrect
information meant to deceive but um
that's the actual definition but for
them that's not what it really is it's
this is this is inconvenient information
but the the main tactic here is to
convince people
not to trust their own powers of
perception their own common sense
we saw this we see this all the time
with the left we saw it all throughout
covid trust the experts they said even
if the experts contradict themselves 10
times in the same sentence still just
accept whatever is the most recent thing
the experts have said
lots of people sadly are not only
willing to do this but they find
i think some comfort in it
the the fire hydrant of information
gushing directly into your brain can get
exhausting and overwhelming at times and
after a while people look to outsource
the task of processing and forming
conclusions to some sort of outside
authority
government's more than happy to provide
that service
now it's created a whole department for
that express purpose
don't bother thinking they say we'll
take care of that
we'll tell you what to think
and then they'll pat you on the head and
give you a lollipop send you on your way
the government has already infiltrated
nearly every aspect of your life the
last thing it can take a hold of is your
mind
if you let it
which you shouldn't well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content